.
Now I want to solve a bunch of examples that deal with
More two types of multiplying multipliers are typical
Which you will see, in algebra
The first is quadrilateral bipolar
If I have (x + 9) ^ 2, I know your intuition
Will this tell you, oh, this is not x ^ 2 + 9 ^ 2?
I will say, no, not so
You have to deal with every desire
When doing this
It is not x ^ 2 + 9 ^ 2
Remember, x (9) ^ 2 equals (x + 9)
× (x + 9)
This is a multiplication of the bipolar phrase itself
You always need to remember that
It is very tempting to think that it is an x ​​^ 2 +
9 ^ 2, but no, you have to expand it
Now that we have expanded it, we can use some of the
The skills we learned in the last show to hit
To make it clear that we can do this in a way
We hit the three-way border once again, let's hit (x +9)
× (x + 9) written in purple
I use this method until I make it clear to you when
Multiply by 9 against this x
But let us use it
If 9 × 9 = 81
Put it in the position of constants
9 x x = 9x
Then we have - move on to the words x these - our
x yellow, if x x 9 = 9 x
Put it in the status of the first degree statement
x x x = x ^ 2
x ^ 2
And then we collect everything
You get x ^ 2 + 18x + 81
This is equal to x ^ 2 + 18x + 81
Now maybe you are seeing a pattern here, and will
Explain this pattern quickly
But what happens when you double-edged words?
We have x ^ 2
We have x these x x, and x x 2
We have 9 × 9, which equals 81
And then we have this phrase which is 18x
How did we get 18x?
Well, we've hit x these by 9 so we get 9x, and then
We hit 9 b x in order to get another 9x
And then we collected the two and we got 18x
If in general, when we have a double-edged box - call me
Use this method
I will use generic terms - suppose we have (a
+ b) ^ 2
(a + b) ^ 2
Let me hit it this way again, even
Attached in your mind
This is equal to (a + b) (a + - I will put
b green here -
If we have b × b = b ^ 2
Let's assume that this is hard
I'll put b ^ 2 here
I suppose this is hard
If this will be hard, be
Its value is 81
a variable abaya - in fact, let me change that
To become better
Let me make it (x + b) ^ 2, and we assume that b
Is hard
X (b) (x + b)
Assuming that b is constant, b × b = b ^ 2
b × x = bx
Then we move to purple x
x x b = bx
Then x x x = x ^ 2
So when we collect everything, we have x ^ 2
+ 2bx + b ^ 2
What you see is, the final winner, what you will get when
You have (x + b) ^ 2, is x ^ 2 + 2 ×
Multiply x and b, + b ^ 2
Using this pattern, let's solve more examples
More examples
I will use the fast way
If (3x - 7) ^ 2
Let's remember what I told you
Not just for remembering, but for you to
You know why it makes sense
If you want to multiply this, using the distribution property
Twice, as you know you will get the same answer
If this equals 3x ^ 2 + 2
× 3x × 7
is not it?
We know that 2 × is the result of each of these statements
+ 7 ^ 2
If we use the multiplication rules here, 3x ^ 2
Equivalent to 9x ^ 2
Here, you will get 2 x 3, whatever
Equals 6, × 7, equals -42x
Then -7 ^ 2 = positive 49
That's the quick way
And to make sure I did not make a mistake
Let me do it in a slow way
(3x - 7) (3x - 7)
-7 × -7 = positive 49
-7 × 3x = -21x
3x × 7 = -21x
3x × 3x = 9x ^ 2
We move to the left slightly
We collect everything
Our remaining 9x ^ 2 - 42x + 49
If we've got the same answer really
Let's solve another issue, and we'll do it in a quick way
If we have 8x - 3 - in fact, let me do one solution
Contains more variables
Suppose we have 4x ^ 2 + y ^ 2, we have that
We square them
Well, the same idea
This is equal to the box for this statement, (4x ^ 2) ^ 2
+ 2 × Multiplication of each of the two terms, 2 ×
(4x ^ 2 × y ^ 2 + (y ^ 2 ^ 2
Any phrase
How much is this?
This is equal to 16 - correct, 4 ^ 2 = 16 - y
(x ^ 2) ^ 2, this equals 2 × 2, if equal
x ^ 4
Then +, 2 × 4 = 8, this
8x ^ 2 y ^ 2
And then (y ^ 2) ^ 2, and equal to y ^ 4
Now, we are dealing with quadratic words
In the following example I want to explain to you that when I take
Total multiplier and difference
This will be organized
I will solve a general example
Let us solve (a + b) (a - b)
If this equals?
This equals a × a - Let me put these
In different colors - if a - b, so
If this is equal to a green × this is a purple, a
A + or maybe I should say - a green
× b these
I've got this negative from here
And then we have these green b, if +
b × a
I hit every phrase with every phrase
Then finally - b green - from here
The negative sign was - - b green
Purple
How much is this?
This is equal to a ^ 2, and then
- ab
These can be rewritten as follows + ab, and then we have
- b ^ 2
These are deleted, ie ab + ab, and
We have a ^ 2 - b ^ 2
It is already a perfect result
Things really simplify
So let's use that concept to do some beatings
If we say (2x - 1) (2x + 1)
Well, this stuff is equivalent
The 2x + 1, you can consider, if you wish, a +
b, and 2x - 1 you can consider a - b, where
That is a, and that b = 1
This b
This is a
Using this style that we have created now
So how much is this?
It equals a ^ 2, equals 2x ^ 2
- b ^ 2 - 1 ^ 2
2x ^ 2 = 4x ^ 2
1 ^ 2 = 1, if - 1
Becoming 4x ^ 2 - 1
Let us solve another example, that
The idea is clear
Okay
I will focus on the beating process now
If I have a 5A-2B, I want to hit this
B 5a + 2b
And remember, this only applies when I have
A multiplication of a sum or difference
Only in this case can I use it
The reason has been explained
If you suspect it, just hit them
This will take you a long time
You will see that the phrases are deleted
You can not do this for any double-edged operation
I saw this at the beginning of the show, when we were
We hit, when we squared them
If this equals, using the style, equals
5a ^ 2 - 2b ^ 2, which equals 25a ^ 2
- 4b ^ 2
And, well, I'll leave you here, and I'll see you in
Next view